[Music]
and my mind's submitted by name the baby
bear honk lon you still have an
opportunity you still have an
opportunity
whatever flames are cool name whatever
you want it's perfect no matter how
about King Kong lon
you can just nickname a long one and
they have no no see that's true no
matter what you Danica did we're naming
and we're gonna call him one toe Reese
is so nice talk to you arise Tori our
Kelly has been accused of running a sex
cult and one of his alleged victims has
come forward what why is why is this a
surprise because I thought everybody
know that he likes pissing on underage
girls and he was married to alia when
she was 15 he was 27 she was 50 yeah I
mean that should have been the DA right
really like this is literally money
let's he do whatever the [ __ ] you want
or maybe everyone's surprised that he
was smart enough to put together a cult
do you think the young people of today
remember who our Kelly is I don't think
so because I'm seeing nothing wrong my
little brother asked me who talked to
TLC was ordered to die who who asked you
that my little brother how little is
your little brother
boy do you need to get your hand yeah
just in yes back he deserves a backhand
where the knuckles [ __ ] go across his
face give me your hand all right little
brother
all right you get his hand and then you
just like I [ __ ] forgot it was gonna
be different
I was cuz in the it was it was TLC and
chasing waterfalls was playing and you
say oh is this and I almost [ __ ]
crashed the car it was terrible I was
driving to an isaac ask me who oh haha
then you say like he was like this new
yeah okay what was it
hit me baby one month that one was
playing when were dry I was driving and
then he was like honey who's this I'm
like Britney Spears he's like is she
youtuber oh my god it's weird now that
um I don't know what channel this is not
BuzzFeed but one of those viral channels
where they have little teenagers
teenagers come in and react to best of
fine brothers that's like teens react
yeah yeah to like elders react all that
so [ __ ] like 90s whatever and for me
it feels like it's music listen out like
a year ago but then they're like who is
this what is it's more like 20 years ago
yeah and I'm watching out to cry myself
to sleep in I still think the 90s was 10
years ago
see save it anyways so are Kelly or
first of all BuzzFeed published an
article last month saying that art Kelly
is holding multiple young women against
their will and that he has this sex cult
but apparently the young women keep
telling their parents and police that
they're there because they want to be in
that they're happy that they're in love
and D face oh yeah then they have also
signed NDA's which is non-disclosure
agreement and so they are also saying
that these women are over the age of 18
so police can't really do anything but
the parents are just really concerned
because they can't speak to other
daughters whenever they do see their
daughters they're saying that they're
like brainwashed and they're just really
worried for their kids because they're
like I wish I could get help and take
them to some sort of like cult
rehabilitation program to like reprogram
them cuz it's like there's zombies how
is he still getting young girls but the
promise of stardom cash he's actually
going to his old high school record and
like we're trying to recruit like for
you know trying to help them with their
singing or you know they're trying to be
artists or whatever they're
he's telling them that he's gonna help
them but then instead he just like
crimes easy young girls but I like
talking to them for months and then he
ends up moving in me like having sex
with them like flying them out to his
concerts and then at the concert it's
having sex with these young girls I
didn't know he still had groupies that
are young high school girls or whatever
well actually no according to this
report these girls that are in his sex
cult they're already like an 18 - like
mid-20 so he's primed them in high
school that's pretty powerful though I
think like if you go to a high school
and like there's notable alumni and
that's what the high school is always
proud of right like oh oh mama went here
or the rock went here then like growing
up starting as a freshman you're always
like all cool to rock the rock the rock
and then when the rock does show up like
hey I could help you guys become movie
stars you're like well of course you
can't really with the same high school
so like all like half of the
brainwashing work I feel like it's
already done
yeah so all our tell us to do is I'll
fly to one my concerts and bam [ __ ]
parents like how are these like 16 year
old girls taking flights and the parents
will say [ __ ] I couldn't believe me they
probably like get their parents into
like you're not gonna help me realize it
could become a song I'm pretty sure
that's that's true cuz we have an alumni
who's the owner of the public storage
company you know those companies were
there yeah and if he came back to my
high school and he was like you know I
have a lot of these public storage
buildings and I can show you guys a
little bit about business I would have
been like really take me to one of your
garages triangle pyramid schemes I
learned so much about manipulating
people like oh I retired my parents at
23 and I'm driving a Lamborghini you
bulb all the kids are like no way then
you [ __ ] hear about the [ __ ] on
Facebook
you know like oh my god you have a Viper
at 22 years old yeah how can I be down
yeah that's how I weed out the dumbasses
on my facebook if I see one [ __ ] about
gusano's I mean like you're [ __ ] out
especially at our age you saw our
Herbalife yeah here's the thing there's
um there's this pyramid scheme thing
where you're like a Beachbody Coach why
is it that every [ __ ] Beachbody Coach
that teaches fitness like their their
life coach Beachbody Coaches after like
three years they're still fat how I
don't know I wouldn't call myself a
coach it even now yeah like all they
post about is workout like oh just said
my 30-minute pitch body workout now it's
so great it's working so well it's like
it's been three years dude you're so fat
what the [ __ ] kind of coach are you how
do you think this all works
it's specially at power age man if
you're getting [ __ ] suckered into any
pyramid scam cult or whatever your
[ __ ] especially that [ __ ] cult
cult choices [ __ ] that call ah watch out
man anybody that's getting into this
[ __ ] at this age you're done I dated
a guy I did if you're 17 or 18 yes
you're still in it like you're like you
learn your world is still kind of like
you're learning what if yeah you don't
know [ __ ] about business you don't know
how it works
if you're like in your late 20s to early
30s and you're getting suckered into
this [ __ ] you're done you didn't see the
world enough saying like I think what
they prey on is there's always everyone
has a sliver of this I feel like we're
how can I get rich or get successful
quick and the more realistic you are the
more you know conspiring to take 10 15
years to become a singer to become an
actor or to build a successful business
but it's all those people that are like
how can I become a millionaire in a
month that's where they prey upon and
that's how people get sucked into have
like their own like inner demons that
they're trying to fight out they're like
well I can't find happiness anywhere
else and I'll try becoming rich yeah
because they're like oh my god you know
this this this special shortcut
and it's not it's like if that's
impossible no one has ever built any
successful business in a month
when I was 17 I dated a guy who went to
this thing called landmark it's a you
know these these calls they also change
names to tell the stories but they
change names because landmark could be
choices possibly possibly but then he
was like yeah it changed my life it
teaches me how to limit defense
mechanisms and you should Oh sounds like
choices yeah and like how to deal with
life problems I went all right cool and
then they would plant people in the
crowd
so whatever the guy says something like
yeah you can do this and someone who
comes like yeah that's right let's go
and then I'm just like shut oh [ __ ] oh
like that's the one thing that made me
not want to go and so I asked him I
asked the guy I was dating I was like so
how much is it for one class so it's 500
bucks I'm like [ __ ] I'm 17
whoa I'll have 500 bucks for this [ __ ]
and then that's when I'm like even at
that age I'm like this [ __ ] stupid
you guys are all dumb in here I go yeah
so these are Kelly girls they're saying
that apparently are Kelly controls their
physical appearance like their weight
their hair
he makes them wear these jumpsuits so no
one else can can see their bodies like
apparently if there's a man in the room
make you some clothes
yeah it really cares about they're warm
if they get sick - I really thought I
explained this one if there's a man in
the room they all have to face the wall
because a man's probably freaking Dirty
Dozen want to contaminate their minds
such a caring guy I wonder if he's still
peeing on them our friend downloaded all
the porn that that he recorded with all
the young girls during that time we were
like 15 okay it was okay to watch this
we were like the same age as the girl
okay and then so I was watching it and
he's like basically recording this on a
home camcorder right there they're
[ __ ] and at the end of it he whips
out his dick and starts peeing on them
and I'm all like that just ruined
everything
that girl is like 14 years old yeah like
we were like the same age
I was like dude everything was done to
people up until the point that he had to
pee on her what the [ __ ] was that was it
like video is it like shittily like
quality like she would go yeah it was
just like a home recorded like sex video
and then I was like before the time of
web cam cam girls and all that stuff you
know I was like dude that's [ __ ] up
that's so much work like he has to stay
hydrated before he has sex she has to go
by like two liters of Aquafina water
when I'm about to come up he first
reason dialing all this water is like
all hella hydrated and then he has to
pee because if it's not stocked up
stocked up on pee counting the pee on
I'm also thinking about how smelly that
room is because you just peed all over
and they didn't clean it up so imagine
all the peas at land it on the floor it
just soaked it up I had a dog that peed
on floors see like you just legs you're
just standing there like like she's just
receiving the piss no how did you clean
up you kept the tape rolling no I mean
like there's pee that's dripping all
over the carpet like I don't see any
mops on the walls or anything
nice I hope to god the maid steam clean
that [ __ ] did it look like a posh place
no I just look like a bedroom actually
wasn't yeah oh yeah apparently he also
switches like he confiscates their
cellphones and he he buys them new cell
phones and they have to ask permission
whenever they leave the home whenever
they even want to go to the restroom
whenever they want to contact anyone
besides him on the phone thing they
always need to ask permission this is
all according to that BuzzFeed article
and so apparently BuzzFeed also
confirmed that there were five women
living in his Chicago recording studio
and that they all have to call him daddy
kuroh hoes yeah and ain't nobody my
daddy but my daddy yeah the one girl
she's now 24 years old her name is
Deronda
she's saying that she first met art
Kelly when she was fifteen back in 2008
she was waiting outside the courtroom
when he was being charged or when he was
on trial for child porn charges
why the [ __ ] she was a fan of
Superman and then so apparently once
here was acquitted of those charges like
that like just cemented in her mind like
he's innocent he's amazing and so she
would continue it happened to her so
then like she would continue to like be
a fan as crazy his management team or
whoever they contacted her via myspace
and then they started talking for months
and then he flew he would fly her to
wherever he was having concerts they
would have sex and then apparently he
was abusive and so now she's speaking
out oh and also she did sign an NDA
because she was told that she would be
getting a certain amount of money for
signing that contract but she's saying
that he never paid her and so now that
all this is coming out about this sex
cult that she she wants to speak out
about her own experience to try to
convince these girls that are with him
now it's to try to get out issues she
likes the managers to that contacted
these girls cuz he did pretty much
helped him get yeah that's true my
friend went on tour with our Kelly he
was a he was a part of the company that
recorded all of his live shows so he was
a cameraman and then saw like for every
single one of his shows like he's like
recording it right and then he says like
he told me so many stories about our
Kelly that I for sure know that this guy
is just [ __ ] insane because do you
remember like when he did his opera [ __ ]
oh you would wear the Cape yeah so he
said that in the middle of his show
right like right in the middle of his
concert he felt that he had to leave in
his [ __ ] Phantom of the Opera cap
outfit go across the street to
McDonald's and start passing out
hamburgers so like he's in there and
it's [ __ ] like opera phantom of the
opera cape and everything and then he's
inside McDonald's and of course because
it's art Kelly like no one's telling him
like get out of here you crazy guy he
goes behind the counter and then he
starts passing out [ __ ] hamburgers
like he's working at McDonald this hit
the whole concerts just waiting for him
to come back Wow
yeah Jo so emotionally charged his mind
is working faster than his mouth yeah so
he's just out there and I was just like
what the [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy the
[ __ ] weirdo yeah there's so many
missing on the fries and stuff yeah oh
yeah now his lawyer is just saying that
our Kelly is alarmed and disturbed about
the recent revelations attributed to him
and that he denied the allegations and
that they are working diligently to try
to pursue his accusers and clear his
name dude
anybody that if you if anyone saw the
trapped in a closet series that he
created it's like a thirty parts
music video 30 episode music me or some
[ __ ]
of the same beat if anyone watches that
you would clearly know that this guy's
insane well apparently he wrote an
autobiography and in a like he's saying
that he got raped by an older woman and
he got like sexually abused by a man and
like all there's like crazy [ __ ]
happened in his childhood so it's like
oh I can kind of see you how like where
it's coming from
if I was the the judge in the courtroom
I would make him sing all the
testimonies yeah I do feel bad for him
though it doesn't justify anything that
he's doing nah but he is a troubled man
he is in trouble man no you know yeah he
was dirt a spore and when he made it I
think it was like 17 or 18 he was really
young and it was almost like being dirt
[ __ ] poor too like yeah yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed this video for more
please subscribe to our Channel and you
can check out the last video right here
[Music]